[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
GEMMA HOLT: So hi, everyone.
Today I'm new talking
about the ongoing efforts
to modernize the Columbia River
Treaty, sort of the agenda.
The Columbia River Treaty was
originally signed in 1961,
so I'm going to go through
the historical context that
led to that.
Signature-- talk about the
1961 treaty negotiations
and outcomes.
And then I'm also going to
talk about the ongoing case
for modernization and the
ongoing treaty negotiation
process.
So covering a lot of
time periods here.
So a little bit of a
geographical overview.
The Columbia River Basin is
over 250,000 square miles,
which is larger than the
entire area of France.
The Basin includes more than
half of Washington and Oregon,
almost all of Idaho, and parts
of Montana, Nevada, Utah,
and Wyoming.
And approximately
15% of the Basin
is in the Canadian province
of British Columbia, where
the Columbia River,
which you can see here
on this map in
purple, originates.
And then in
southeastern Washington,
the Columbia River
meets the Snake River,
and together that feeds
into the Pacific Ocean.
So the United States and
Canada have a long history
of bilateral cooperation.
They share the longest
international border
between two countries, and
their bilateral negotiations
date back for centuries.
As far as water diplomacy
goes, the origin of this
is the 1909 Boundary
Waters Treaty,
which was signed to come up
with an approach for preventing
and resolving disputes over
the use of shared waters.
It established an
international joint commission
to help the two countries
carry out its provisions.
And at the time,
disputes over water,
most notably on the Niagara
River on the East Coast,
were already creating
tension along the border.
So the treaty provided
this framework
to deal with these disputes.
It held its first
meeting in 1912,
and it has worked over
the last century plus
to resolve more than
100 matters raised
by the two federal governments.
So the Columbia River Treaty
more specifically came
about during this era
of hydropower expansion
in the United States
and Canada, which
is symbolized in the 1930s with
the construction of the Grand
Coulee Dam in Washington.
And during about
a 20-year period,
more than a dozen large dams
were built in the Columbia
River Basin--
mostly for hydroelectric
power purposes,
but they also benefited
flood control, navigation,
and other irrigation projects.
The construction
of these dams had
and continues to have
a negative impact
on the ecosystems of the Basin.
For example, the completion
of the Grand Coulee Dam
eliminated salmon runs from
the mainstream Columbia River
and its tributaries
in British Columbia.
So the specific impetus for
the Columbia River treaty
was a major flood in 1948.
The river was abnormally high
due to deep snowfall and large
rainstorms.
And it breached a dike
in Vanport, Oregon, which
is an industrial suburb
outside of Portland,
and the town was
completely submerged.
18,000 residents were displaced,
51 people were killed,
and the estimated property
damage was over $100 million.
So you can see here on the
right a picture of the town
right after the flood.
So the original treaty
emerged in response
to these two, one trend
of hydropower development
and then the specific
flood control
needs that were raised
by the Vanport flood.
So agreeing to agree.
In 1944, Canada and
the US had requested
that the IJC determine whether
a greater use than is now
being made of the waters of
the Columbia River System
would be feasible
and advantageous.
And then four years later,
after the Vanport flood,
detailed studies began.
And what followed was 11 years
of discussions and analysis,
two requests by the US
for approval of the Libby
Dam in Montana, which
is pictured behind me,
my virtual background.
Two proposals by
Columbia River companies
to build Canadian dams,
committee hearings in the US
Senate and the
Canadian Parliament,
and a gradual acceptance
by the US of the idea
of sharing downstream US
hydroelectric benefits.
So 11 years of
negotiations and then
another round of
formal negotiations
began in February of 1960.
And then ultimately the
Columbia River treaty
is signed by President
Eisenhower and Prime Minister
Diefenbaker on January 17, 1961.
The US Senate approved
it almost immediately,
but ratification took an
additional three years
in Canada, largely due to
British Columbia needing
to negotiate with the
Canadian federal government
to clarify issues of
authority and responsibility.
So that was the original round
of negotiation processes.
And the treaty as it emerged
has two primary focuses--
hydroelectric power
and flood control.
The terms of the
treaty specified
that Canada would provide
about 15 million acre
feet of storage
usable for improving
the flow of the Columbia River.
This is really for
flood control purposes
to minimize downstream
flood damages in both the US
and Canada.
And as compensation, the US
made three lump sum payments
totaling $64.4 million to Canada
when the dams were completed,
and that amount was based
on an estimate of half
of the present value of future
US flood damages prevented.
So the operation of the
Columbia River Treaty storage
creates hydropower
benefits in both countries,
and the CRT requires
that the downstream power
benefits in the US
due to the operation
of the Canadian storage
be shared equally
between the two countries.
This is known as the
Canadian entitlement.
And under the terms
of the treaty,
Canada can opt to sell
the entitlement back
to buyers in the US.
And actually to pay for
construction of the dams,
British Columbia sold
the Canadian entitlement
to a consortium of utilities
in the US for 30 years
beginning in 1964.
So the treaty really is premised
on this idea of mutual gains
to both countries, both
in terms of flood control
and hydroelectricity.
However, there were
also losses created.
Most notably the treaty
made no explicit provision
for other values such as
water flow benefits for salmon
and steelhead, continuing to
exacerbate these ecosystem
problems created by this
era of hydropower expansion.
So these are the three.
Here you can see a map of all
of the dams in the system.
The three dams in
Canada up here.
Can you see my mouse?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Yeah.
GEMMA HOLT: In purple and
the Libby Dam in Montana.
So those were the
four dams that were
built as a result of the
Columbia River Treaty.
But the consequences
of the treaty
affect the entire
hydroelectric power generation
across the entire basin.
So it's very involved,
even though there
are only three dams
actually generated
as a result of the treaty.
So the treaty has
been widely regarded
as an example of
successful cooperation
and successful transboundary
negotiations really built
on this foundation
of mutual gains.
In 2011, when the
renegotiation process began,
the British Columbia
government came out
with a statement saying that
the Columbia River is known
throughout the world
as one of the most
successful models of a
transboundary water treaty.
Other countries
see the agreement
as a benchmark on cooperation
to create and share benefits.
So I thought that was an
interesting statement.
And while the
treaty did authorize
this equal sharing of
additional hydropower,
results from the
additional water storage,
and coordinated water
releases, there were also--
negative impacts of the dams
weren't necessarily equally
shared by the two countries.
So the United States had fairly
significant adverse impacts
on fish and salmon habitat
and some losses of land.
But in Canada, as a
result of the three dams
that were constructed, there was
major flooding and dislocation
of entire communities.
So Canada, although they were
ultimately compensated for it,
did have more significant
negative impacts
as a result of the treaties.
So the case for modernization--
the Columbia River Treaty
has no expiration date,
but 2024 is
significant because it
is the earliest that
the terms of the treaty
can be terminated.
And so without renegotiation--
also in addition
to the termination provision,
without renegotiation,
the flood control
provisions will shift.
So this presents an opportunity
for the United States
and Canada, as well
as other stakeholders
on both sides of the
border, to reconsider
the scope of the treaty and
evaluate its effectiveness.
And I think within a water
diplomacy framework, the fact
that this renegotiation
process is
baked into the initial
agreement is a strength.
We can talk about whether the
60-year timeline is too long.
But I think it is
interesting that none
of the original
negotiators expected
that the original agreement
would last forever.
But at the same time, this has
also introduced some measure
of conflict, I guess, because
everyone wants the treaty
to be updated in a way that
reflects their priorities
and values.
So thinking about
modernization, which
is the word being used
by the negotiators,
there's five main
issues that have
been raised during these
ongoing conversations.
This is not an exhaustive
list-- lots of other things
have been brought
up as well, but I
think it summarizes the most
significant arguments, so I'm
going to walk through
each of these five.
So first as I mentioned,
issue number one
is that 2024, the current flood
risk management provisions
change to a less
defined approach.
And instead of Canada
providing a set amount
of flood control
every year, it will
be as-- on an on-call
basis, and the US
will pay on an
annual basis based
on how much flood risk
has been assessed.
So this is the core part
of the original treaty,
and it will expire
unless measures are
taken to renew or modify it.
And in addition, it
is the earliest date
at which the treaty can
be terminated, provided
that either Canada
or the United States
provides 10 years
written notice.
No one has provided
this, so the treaty
will not be terminated in 2024.
But it catalyzed this
era of renegotiations
beginning around 2011, 2012.
That's issue one.
Issue number two is that since
the original treaty negotiation
process in the 1960s,
stakeholders outside
of the main negotiating parties
have argued that the treaty
neglects ecosystem needs.
So the renegotiation
process has opened
the door for a variety of
environmental advocates.
And in particular, the dams
built as a result of the treaty
have altered the river's ecology
and contributed to the decline
of salmon fisheries.
So in a 1995 opinion on the
impacts of the entire Columbia
River power system on
salmon, NOAA, the National
Oceanographic Association,
had set flow objectives
at each of the Columbia
River Basin dams.
And in the last 20
years, the spring target
has been missed roughly
27% of the time.
So 27% of time, there's
not adequate flow
at these dams for
salmon to pass.
And the initial study
is about renegotiation,
the US and Canadian
entities didn't address
any of these ecosystem needs.
They only addressed updating
the power and flood control
agreements, although
subsequent documents
have addressed incorporating
more ecosystem-based function
requirements.
So you can see here on
this map on the right
where there are salmon
passages and where
the dams have prevented
any kind of fish migration.
So almost everything north
of the Canadian border,
the salmon habitats has
been completely destroyed.
And in particular
groups that have
been harmed by the
original treaty
and who have
advocated consistently
for considering salmon habitats
are the Canadian First Nations
and United States
Native American tribes.
And you can see here on the
right, the historical land
of the Yakama, Umatilla, Nez
Perce, and Warm Springs tribes
who have formed a
coalition to advocate
for incorporating
ecosystem functions
in the modernized treaty.
And that group came out
with a statement recently
that said that any
modifications to the treaty
must ensure full engagement and
consent from tribes and First
Nations and be in alignment
with articulated Indigenous
governance principles.
So they're advocating
essentially
for expanding the
formal negotiation
team to include representatives
from Native American tribes
and First Nations.
Next, stakeholders responding
to these needs on both sides
have identified
ecosystem functions
as a key component of
a modernized treaty.
The US came out and
said that there's
an opportunity for inclusion
of certain additional ecosystem
operations, and the BC side,
the British Columbia side
said basically the
exact same statement.
There is certainly a lack of
clarity about what exactly
ecosystem functions mean.
It's become a buzzword within
this negotiation process,
and a lot of stakeholders
trying to advocate
for clarifying and determining
what exactly are we
thinking about
when we're talking
about ecosystem functions.
And then finally, the terms
of the Canadian entitlement
have led to conditions that
disadvantage US electricity
consumers.
Because the Canadian
Entitlement specifies
that all power
generated downstream
would be split evenly among
the United States and Canada,
although the energy market
has changed considerably
since 1964.
So the original
economic assumptions
were based on forecasts of
declining downstream power,
but these proved
to be incorrect.
And so the power
sharing agreement
has ultimately been
more favorable to Canada
than to the US,
and the US entity
has proposed rebalancing
the power benefits
to better reflect
the actual value
of the coordinated operations.
However, some
Northwest politicians
believe that the terms of
the treaty are beyond repair
and introduced a
bipartisan resolution
in the United States
House of Representatives
calling for its termination.
While this seems unlikely,
it is another sticking point
in the renegotiation process.
So formal negotiations
opened on May 30 in 2018,
and in June 2020, the 10th
round of treaty negotiations
occurred via web conference.
And at the conclusion of those
most recent conversations,
the two sides released almost
identical press statements,
which I excerpted on this slide.
Due to the confidential
nature of the cross-border
negotiations, the
specific details
of Canada's initial proposal
and of the US framework
that they're referencing here
have not been made public.
And this lack of
information has been
really frustrating to the
numerous stakeholders who
regard modernizing the
treaty as essential.
So in 2018, a coalition of
31 nonprofit organizations
sent a letter to the
US entity advocating
for, among other things, the
expansion of the US negotiating
team to include a broader range
of stakeholders and greater
transparency in the
negotiation process.
So I'll talk a little bit about
how the negotiations actually
work.
Each side is represented
by an entity.
The US entity is made up
of the State Department,
the Bonneville Power
Administration,
which covers multiple states
in the Pacific Northwest,
and then Northwest Division of
the US Army Corps of Engineers.
And the Canadian
entity is represented
by the Canadian Department
of Foreign Affairs, Trade,
and Development, and the
BC Hydro Power Authority.
And so these are the
formal negotiators.
But in addition to
those teams, there
are numerous other stakeholders
who are not formally
involved in the
negotiation process
but have claims to the Basin.
So these include, for example,
states and their legislators,
a large assortment of
NGOs and other nonprofits,
public utility
districts, and tribes
in both the United
States and Canada.
So as far as thinking
about what comes next
and trying to imagine how
this treaty might resolve,
as I said, the negotiations are
still very much in progress,
and there's not a ton
of information about how
things have been evolving.
That said, there seems to be
a consensus emerging around
how they can leverage the
treaty to address ecosystem
functions and other
environmental concerns
such as climate change.
This seems to be a
priority for many
of the non-formal
stakeholders, and that
has been reflected in statements
made by the US and Canadian
entities.
There are lots of
stakeholders who
all have various views
about how the treaty should
be modernized,
and there are even
some stakeholders who believe
that a formal treaty is
unnecessary.
So I think there is a more--
I think it's unlikely that
actually emerges as an option,
but there's a question of
whether the two sides could
cooperate on flood control
without a formal treaty
or whether good treaties
make good neighbors.
So that's where
we're at with this.
Thank you all for listening.
DR. GAIN: Yeah,
thank you, Gemma,
for the excellent presentation.
I think it's really nice the
way that you have presented.
It's really wonderful.
So now I would like to ask
Mashroof and Flora to make
the comments.
And yeah, then we
can discuss further.
AUDIENCE: So what
would you think
would be the biggest challenge
to overcome from the government
side?
GEMMA HOLT: I think it's
this fundamental question
of the treaty that they have has
basically worked for 60 years,
and people have been pretty
happy with it on both sides.
The US feels like they're
overpaying for power,
but that's been the main
objection to the treaty
as it currently stands.
However, I think there is
a fairly broad consensus
that the treaty should be--
the scope of the treaty should
be expanded to include all
of these ecosystems-- not all
of these ecosystem services,
but certain ecosystem services
relating to salmon fisheries
and climate change.
And I think figuring out--
I think the biggest
challenge for the government
is figuring out
to what extent are
we going to transform this
treaty that has basically
worked for 60 years
and broaden the scope
of these negotiations, which I
think is just a slippery slope.
And is this treaty as--
even the right vehicle
for having those conversations
about transboundary
environmental concerns?
I don't know.
I'm not sure I actually
have an answer to that one.
Yeah, I think that's
the biggest challenge.
AUDIENCE: I'm also
thinking something
that since the climate
changes in the--
climate change has very
much been the issue,
so help me understand
this because I'm not
that much familiar with
the US government system.
So I was thinking that, for
example, the last government
of the US, as far as
my understanding goes,
not really very
supportive of the measures
to be taken about the climate
change and everything.
And I know that in the US,
there is spoiler system.
Once the government changes,
almost a major portion
of the administration changes.
So with this shift
of administration,
do you think that will
have a significant effect
on making the future
decisions on this treaty?
And if yes, then how
that might end up?
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah.
I think I would venture yes.
I think that even under
the Trump administration,
climate change still
featured in this treaty
because if, for example, there
is less snowmelt or less snow
accumulation because
of a changing climate,
that has serious impacts on US
hydroelectric power generation
and the economy of the
Pacific Northwest--
I think 40% of Washington
electricity is hydroelectric.
So if there's less water,
there's less power,
and that's quite devastating
to the Northwest economy.
So to that extent,
I think it impacts--
the potential impacts of
climate change on this treaty
had already been taken
into consideration,
whether under the current
administration that
might be expanded
to include more
comprehensive environmental
values, it seems possible.
I also think that this treaty
is not a major foreign policy
priority for either government.
So it's skated under
the radar a little bit.
And during some of the-- there
were 10 rounds of negotiations,
and then it was put on hold
during the changing government.
So I think whether
it will be picked up
with more focus on
environmental concerns I
think remains to be seen.
AUDIENCE: Actually
both the questions
came from my experience
as a government officer.
Because in our case,
in the US or in most
of the developed
countries, generally what I
see that although the
governments change
but the national policies and
the national rules more or less
remain the same.
Very minor changes unless some
drastic measures are taken.
But in this part of the
world, the government changes,
the whole thing falls apart and
you start from the beginning.
So this is why I was trying
to actually understand
this thing so that I can
actually design my presentation
on paper from that perspective.
Thank you very much.
It was an amazing
presentation, and I loved it.
DR. GAIN: Thanks, Mashroof.
Flora, do you have any
feedback or concern for Gemma?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah,
I really, really
enjoyed this presentation.
Great job.
I appreciate your
use of graphics.
I think making a
presentation is--
a good presentation is always
not as easy as it seems.
So yeah, overall, I
think I learned a lot.
It was very easy to follow.
I definitely had
a couple of points
that I would consider as further
considerations, not really
necessary but things that came
to mind while I was listening
to the presentation.
So I'll run through, and you
can either respond or not
respond to each one.
So the first one is, are
there still opportunities
for further hydropower expansion
along the Columbia River?
Because you mentioned that
flooding is still a priority.
But I know a lot of parts of
the world hydropower expansion
is really diminishing because
we're just utilizing everything
that we can.
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah, so
in my understanding,
there are no opportunities for
additional dam construction.
There are opportunities
for greater efficiency,
like greater
electric efficiency.
Some dams have been identified
as potential targets
for removal, which
would then catalyze
additional needs on the
existing dams for flood control
measures.
Yeah, those are the categories.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and
so then the next one--
so you talked about
this a little bit,
especially at the end,
but I was wondering
how climate change might
exacerbate the water
resources in the future.
And I guess specifically,
if certain stakeholders
should be included.
So you already mentioned a lot
of stakeholders that are not
being included, but it
would be interesting
if like ecologists, either
like representing the two
countries or some kind of
neutral ecology representation
to be included in
the negotiations
to really advocate for these
environmental needs and not
just the wants of
the two countries,
like economically
or technologically.
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah,
that's a great question.
I think one of the
suggestions that
has emerged in recent years
is officially adding NOAA
to the US entity
team to have a better
advocate for environmental
impacts in that formal body.
That is one of the things.
Or other representatives
from the US Department
of the Interior
that could be more
of a voice for
environmental concerns
compared to the power
administrations who
have clear expertise on
the hydroelectric side
but aren't necessarily equipped
to consider salmon habitats
and things like that.
So that's one of the strategies
that has been proposed.
Has not happened yet.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
OK so the next thing is about--
so you did a good job of
explaining the gains and losses
from the treaty's
point of view--
like which parties
were suffering
and which ones were
really experiencing gain.
But it'd be interesting
to learn more about how
this treaty was successful
in terms of negotiations.
So not just the effects
of the treaty itself
but also if people are
saying that this is the model
negotiation treaty.
I'm sure it's not just
because of what the treaty was
able to achieve, but also how
the treaty was negotiated.
I think that's one of the
most interesting things
about your presentation
is that it basically
refers to no animosity
between the countries.
It took a really,
really long time,
like decades of negotiations,
but like almost nowhere
in your presentation
did you mention,
well, they really got
stuck on this one issue
or they couldn't move forward
because this one party was not
cooperating.
And I don't know,
I think it would
be interesting to
understand like why is that.
It must have something to
do with the negotiations
and then also probably the
conditions of what's happening.
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah,
that's a great point.
I have not really built
that in, but I think that--
yeah, that's super helpful.
I'd definitely do that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think an
easy way is like looking
at the Bruno Verdini's 12 steps
and just checking off which
ones seem to be fulfilled
and then which ones don't.
Because I imagine
many are checked
and then that's why
it was effective.
But yeah, no, it was
really interesting.
I think it's a big
shift from the case
that I'm working on we're like
basically the governments hate
each other and that's why
nothing is able to get forward.
And I think it's just
interesting to see
how long the timeline is
even if the governments don't
hate each other.
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah, I was thinking
I was thinking a lot about that
after listening to
Husnain's case last week.
And the two-- they
kind of arrived--
the US and Canada arrived
at the negotiating table
with this idea of
mutual gains in mind.
And the treaty emerged
from that, and it wasn't--
it's not that the
treaty is enabling
an effective diplomatic
relationship.
The treaty is the result
of an effective diplomatic
relationship.
So how that differs
and how that might
be leveraged for a
more comprehensive and
forward-looking
document going forward.
Yeah, that's great.
Thank you so much, Flora.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no.
I'm just trying to see--
OK, so the last thing
that I had was--
I mean, you mentioned this as
one of your open questions.
But it's really interesting
what the consequences
for the different
stakeholders would be
if the treaty was terminated.
I think it seems like
everyone's on the same page
that this treaty's
working, it's good.
But then it's really
weird that they're
unable to extend the treaty.
It seems like mainly
just because people
are dragging their feet.
But , yeah it seems like in most
cases, if the treaty went away,
stakeholders would
have some kind of loss.
But I don't know.
DR. GAIN: Yeah, thanks, Flora.
Very constructive suggestions.
So any other suggestions
from, I don't know,
Cassiano or Husnain?
OK, so yeah, I would
like to ask one thing.
Maybe Mashroof touched upon it.
You mentioned five
areas of new--
uh, the renegotiation process.
And so what are the
disagreements among these areas
that you mentioned
among the two parties
between Canada and the US?
Was there a, uh, were you able
to explore the disagreement
among the parties for
those areas that can--
a negotiation might [? stack? ?]
GEMMA HOLT: I think one of
the things that's interesting
about this case is that the
disagreement isn't necessarily
between the two entities
but also between all
of these peripheral--
or not even peripheral.
They're deeply involved.
They're just not part
of the formal process.
So one of the things that's
been so interesting looking
through all of the
documents that have been--
or the statements that have been
put out by the US and Canada
is how identical they are.
And so after each
round of negotiations,
they put up these
statements like,
oh, we made so much progress.
We responded to
their framework, we
responded to their framework.
Things are moving right along.
And all of the
complexity seems to be
driven by these other actors
who are pushing for change.
So I'm not sure if
there's necessarily
a ton of disagreement between
the two countries around, say,
the inclusion of Indigenous
peoples in the negotiation
process.
I think both countries
are willing to expand
the scope of the treaty to think
about how those tribes have
been harmed over
the last 60 years.
But the conflict then is how
does the collaborative treaty
mechanism respond to the
needs of these stakeholders
on both sides of the border?
Does that answer your question?
DR. GAIN: Yep.
Yeah, yeah, thanks.
So the second
issue that I wanted
to mention that you
mentioned climate science
is one of the future aspects
that need to be considered.
So is there any study
that can provide
details of what are the expected
impacts of the climate science?
Is it future flooding, or is it
the impact on energy hydropower
generation?
So I think if you can
mention those impacts,
I think then it
could be much more--
I think your succession
could be much more solid.
GEMMA HOLT: Yes, I think I left
that out for complexity's sake
here, but I think
the main concern is
this shift from a basin that's
driven by snowmelt to a basin
that's driven by rain.
And as there is less
snowmelt and more rain,
the kind of flood control
mechanisms change, as well as
the potential management
of hydropower over time.
So yes, I do have
sources for that,
and I will include those
in my final case study.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Gemma,
I've mentioned to you
a couple of times along
the way that it's invisible
but the states and the
provincial governments
in Canada are in fact very
much calling the shots.
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: And
they're not officially
part of the entities.
But remember that the US entity
is led by the State Department
because allegedly this is an
international negotiation,
and the State Department
has no relationships
with the governors
of all those states,
no long-standing working
relationships, which
has caused some severe
difficulty for those governors.
It may be-- you don't
have to do this--
but you might want to imagine
as a last little piece
of your paper what
it might be like
and how helpful it
might be to imagine
a second track of negotiations
convened by the US
governors and the
provincial leadership
in BC with First
Nations and tribes.
They would have
enormous credibility.
They said, we're
getting together
because we are convinced that
the future of this agreement,
whether it's strengthened
or renewed or replaced,
it needs to take account
of the changing conditions
from 60 years ago,
and we feel those
when we have responsibilities.
And if they were to
organize a set of sessions
with NGOs and
[INAUDIBLE] on their own.
The State Department I
promise you would [INAUDIBLE]
the same way that the Canadian
agencies would show up,
but they wouldn't be there
in their official capacity.
And if they just took
three or four questions,
maybe even two or
three questions
that are not addressed for the
future in the existing treaty
and laid out substantively
agreements they might reach,
the same way that Bruno
described local officials
on both sides of
the US-Mexico border
initiating their
own conversations,
trying to come up
with what they'd
like to see as jointly
beneficial elements
of a future supplementary
agreement, which then became
the basis of what the US
government negotiated,
I think the same
thing could happen.
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: And I
think the two big differences
between then and
now are that there
were enormous number
of positive benefits
to be shared in the beginning.
GEMMA HOLT: Yep.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: And so
they were getting together--
I agree that everyone
who pointed out they
start with friendly
relationships, it matters.
But when the actual
negotiators sat down--
OK, how much flood control
are you going to give me?
Well, how much money are
you going to give me?
And that was the negotiation.
Whereas now it's,
OK, what restrictions
are we going to impose?
What dams are we
going to take down?
Who's going to build
the new flood control
systems if you take down
existing dams to make
salmon migration possible?
It's not all about
allocating gains.
That's one big difference.
The second is, nobody
had those concerns
about salmon and climate
and other natural resource
questions and ecological
concerns the way we do now,
and that's not represented
well in the entities.
But the concerns are there,
but the entities can't really
negotiate them very well.
So I think if you look at
what's different in big ways
between then and now
that the response to that
would be most effective
in the short term
is to have a different track
of local and non-governmental
and scientific
negotiators generate
some of the elements of a
supplementary subsidiary
version or addition to
the existing agreement.
And I think the
governors in those states
have been tracking every
move in the State Department.
I mean, my engagement.
In this case-- I
think I mentioned--
happened when I was doing
training for the State
Department, and the two guys
who were appointed by the State
Department to lead
these conversations who
had zero, zero
background in anything
Northwest, water, Canada.
They were absolutely
just thrown into this
and they were saying,
so, we got a problem.
These governors are
telling us that they
want to say what should
happen, and we don't know
how should we negotiate that.
That was the question
they were asking
me is, how should we
do this negotiation
with these governors
who don't have
any official role while
we're trying to negotiate
with the Canadians.
That was the conversation.
I don't think they
figured it out,
and I think there's enormous
pressure coming on the US
government from the states.
GEMMA HOLT: That's a
thing I've been trying
to untangle is the
relationship of state
governments to their
representatives
back to the federal government
because so many state
representatives and senators
from the Northwest states
have come out with
various official
statements and their perspective
on these renegotiations.
And how are the
Washington senators
coordinating with the
Washington governor
to get things back to
the State Department,
like trying to tease
out all of those--
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: They're not.
GEMMA HOLT: They're not?
That's for show.
That's-- we're trying to
make political capital
on the legislative side.
The key is the governors.
The key is the governors have
the access to the White House.
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
The governors only
care later about getting
the Senate to ratify
any change in the treaty.
Between now and then, the
House of Representatives,
the governors don't
care to talk to them.
There's nothing they're
going to do for this.
So my sense is that when
you see state legislators
and congressional legislators
from the states making noise
about this issue, it's
political self-promotion
to try to gain some
advantage from all of this.
But it isn't because they
expect to be part of solving it.
GEMMA HOLT: Got it.
That's good to know.
That's helpful.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: But it
is wonderful to have somebody
say it was a successful treaty.
Yeah, I think that's great.
A successful water treaty
between two countries.
Wonderful.
GEMMA HOLT: It's
basically worked
the way it was supposed
to for a long time.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: And we
have parallel negotiations
after 50 years in Latin America.
We didn't spend much
time on it, but there
are negotiations between
different countries
in Latin America where treaties
that existed over shared
waters for 50 years are up.
And you can't just
extend the treaty.
Everything has changed so much.
But nobody knows,
well, but we've
had this treaty in 50
years, it's worked.
Why should we mess with it?
Well, because the
conditions are all changed.
But that doesn't translate
into a specific strategy
for how to do the negotiation.
In my view, if there is
anything we've learned,
it's that you need to get
all the stakeholders--
I mean Aron, one of
his four conclusions,
you need to get all the
stakeholders into this story.
Well, you can't do that in an
official treaty renegotiation.
So you have to run
a parallel effort
and get the other stakeholders
into the substance of
what should the new
agreement say and why.
And as Bruno has shown,
if you can get agreement
at the next level down from
the National government
on the two sides and you have
real players with stakes,
and they say, this
is what we think.
Whether it's you're
changing the treaty,
you're extending it with
a new supplementary terms.
However you doing it,
here's the substance,
and we all agree with it,
and we'll all support it.
That for me is what
a diplomacy framework
meshes with the political
reality of the treaty
renegotiation.
But I think the
presentation was terrific.
It's such an interesting
circumstance.
I don't think you can conclude
anything at this stage,
but I think you can say, as you
have, look, this is a problem.
Treaty renegotiation,
treaty extension.
Here's what they face.
Here is how they got into it.
Here's what they're trying.
Maybe they could try this.
But I don't think
anyone can hold you
or anyone else to
trying to come up
with a conclusion about
anything in this case
at this stage of the game.
GEMMA HOLT: I think we're at
the lessons learning phase more
than we're at the
lessons learned phase.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Yeah.
GEMMA HOLT: Maybe in a few
years, someone can update it.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I hope so.
We'll give them your
paper to start with.
DR. GAIN: So, thanks, Gemma
again, for the presentation.
And also thanks--
GEMMA HOLT: Thank you
all for your feedback.
DR. GAIN: For the presentation.
So next week, we'll
have last two cases
by Mashroof and Flora.
And as I already mentioned that
the deadline for submission
is on 21st of May.
So yeah, we are expecting
much more [INAUDIBLE]
presentation and also much
more final piece of your work
in the next week.
And as I already mentioned
that please provide
your feedback by May 24.
I guess you already--
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Yeah,
on the whole course.
DR. GAIN: Yeah, for
the whole course.
[INAUDIBLE] already.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
Add a footnote
to what Animesh
said at the outset.
MIT has this online,
give it a rating,
here's a set of questions.
And then they say
what the average score
was on each question by
averaging across whoever
happened to answer.
I do not find this
system helpful.
I've never learned
anything from that device,
and I have always asked
people to please just
send a paragraph, something.
What do you think the
strengths and weaknesses
of the course are,
and what idea do you
have about something we
could do to improve it
in a conversational
just rough draft email.
That's how I learn stuff
about what we do in the course
and how to improve it.
So yes, MIT would like
you to please fill out
the formal evaluation
form, and we'll
live with whatever the numerical
score is, whatever that means.
But we really would like to
learn something from you.
We made a decision to have
guest presenters, particularly
guest presenters.
Did we make good choices?
Did we give them good advice
about how to structure
what they were presenting?
Animesh and I tried to provide
the water diplomacy framework
in some more exploratory
way at the outset.
We asked everyone to pick
a case and write a case.
We used the Aquapedia
frame so that people
have some common
device because it's
worth it because we've published
your paper in the Aquapedia.
I mean, so we make a
bunch of decisions.
Those could all be different.
DR. GAIN: Yeah, and
also the last thing
I would like to mention that
last year two students-- so
one of the students was able
to submit their final paper
into a journal article.
So it's already submitted in
one of the journal article.
Another student is
still working on that,
and another student
was able to publish
their article in a newspaper.
So this kind of thing says--
these are the practical things.
So all these are the
possibilities that you can do,
and I am happy to support you.
So yeah, I think--
yeah, it's very practical.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: It's
very encouraging to us
that there's peer
acceptance and excitement
about the things that are
produced in the course.
So we tell the stories of
people whose papers became
theses or dissertations
or their papers
became articles in
peer-reviewed journals
or their papers
turned into op eds.
This is all for us one
indicator that people
are getting something
out of the thinking,
reading, writing, listening,
talking that happens
in the course.
So we hope you'll think
of a way to capitalize
on all the work you did
in some other outlets
if you can, and we'll help.
We'll help.
In some cases, it
takes another year
to deal with the journal
that wants more elaboration.
And we'll be glad
online to help you
if you want to follow
up on any of this.
DR. GAIN: Is there any
other specific issue
that you would like
to mention maybe
for the final paper
or other issue?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Everybody's
just doing some wonderful work,
and we're very excited
about the products.
See everybody next week
for the last go at this.
All right.
DR. GAIN: Bye.
See you next week.
GEMMA HOLT: Thank you all.
DR. GAIN: Thank you, everybody
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
Great work today.
Thanks!